[Musique]
mathilde facteurs qu'il était fameux
votre toit aurait fait pas dire
excellent c'était du bon poisson
poursuivre la chair bien ferme ce bon
goût le maire ça se sent parfum qui là
que je les péchés ce matin à rennes / du
slalom en effet le texte qui va croire
ça marchera mieux ça fait du bien de
manger de temps en temps légèrement sur
lle vous en train de prétendre que monk
loi ce n'est pas gros vous le trouvez
gros bout je ne sais pas comment je le
trouve enfin je sais que moi moi qui ai
un bon appétit bien les plus fins du
tout or d'écouté vous n'allez tout de
même pas vous disputez et n'a germé vous
le trouvez grand sens passant mon
poisson n'est pas petit vous avez raison
tous les deux ce poisson est moyen là il
ne fait pas si petit que ça en fin de
compte ouais salage et j'admets qu'il
n'est pas vraiment gros enfin il était
bien grand ça il était très bon et c'est
ça le principal à tout à fait vrai pour
sûr et puis c'était vivaces aussi à
tenez je renverrai toujours le moment où
ma canne à pêche s'est enfoncé dans
l'eau et vient ensuite en tandem ou
parce courbet à je tirais non mais vous
partez à pardonner maman cher ami mais
j'ai un rendez vous très urgent avec une
personnalité encore de femmes merci
beaucoup et à très bientôt monsieur dsna
mais bien et moi aussi j'ai un travail
qui m'attend secteur je suis désolé
enfin merci pour le boisseau au revoir à
tout à l'heure
françois je ne les comprends pas
mademoiselle julie c'est vrai je suis
j'allais le raconter comment j'ai
cherché mon poisson pas les voilà tous
les opus live qui s'en vont à coup sûr
rien ne les intéresses cela à la vérité
facteur c'est la quatrième fois que vous
la racontez votre pêche
je vous en prie j'avais déjà eu la
gentillesse de me faire cuire le poisson
alors moi je peux bien débarrasser la
table mais mais mais vous avez mangé
toute façon ça c'est pas gentil alors
quasi mieux tu en as une audace tu es
parti tout à l'heure en dix ans et il
était tellement petit que ça ne valait
même pas la fin de nos goûters un
morceau sera pour sûr et ça ne m'a pas
fait plaisir on mange en aura quand même
bien côté un morceau j'ai tellement faim
et bien tant pis pour toi tu attendras
parce que j'ai pas le temps de m'occuper
de toi oh c'est dommage ça sent très bon
les fameux au magazine ici si tu le sais
j'ai dû parler calmement tout cas c'est
comprendre j'ai pris femme en morceaux
le famille de travers j'ai confié mois
d'arrêt ouais c'est ça ouais c'est de
lui donner de la voix
allez je ne venais pas avez vous besoin
d'autres avec de l'ami gilles abry
casimir à les facteurs attendons de
titane et la brioche à l'achat malin la
voilà voilà
là bas il faudrait lui donner un verre
d'eau la limonade ça vient ça vient
casimir a très vite vite vite vite vite
ce qui avait poussé les filets wassa
casimir voilà alors à mieux ça va comme
ça je lis tout est bien qui s'est dévoué
moi je voulais aller au revoir à tout à
l'heure
bah je vais aller la jetez moi cet art
est bon puisque tout va bien maintenant
je te laisse moi je m'en vais travailler
on va aussi tiens j'ai beaucoup de
choses à faire
c'était c'était bien bon cette brioche à
la limonade
or j'ai faim moi j'en mangerais bien
encore un peu j'ai une idée c'est encore
possible en les imitant à tankessé mieux
tu veux
la boillat chassot allez vas-y vas-y lui
aura again voilà là mais décidément
alors attention sérieuse la tête la
dépêche toi judy davis mais ce soutien
nous ayons bassam on vient ça valait ben
oui oui allez ça fait rien alors s'est
passé ah non mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire je les jeunes idée qui lui donne
une autre tranche de brioche mais à tata
dans avec de la confiture pour coller
l'arête voilà alors ça non obama mais la
porte se fera tous ses environs toujours
à vue dans la confiture pour coller
l'art est inquiète paquette paquette
voilà sa part c'est ça voilà que se
passe-t-il ici facteurs casimir à avaler
une autre arrêt comment c'était possible
et pourquoi ce que j'ai emporté le plat
avec moi pour jouer tout le poids ce au
regard des dix dont casimir
qu'est ce que tu penses de sa masse ses
bras
je n'avais pas avalé l'arrêt mais
j'avais très très fin et alors la
brioche avec la confiture et la moutarde
c'est une recette génial
[Musique]